Jacob markstrom out with a flu so that means
Dusty nickel yes this is your chance he has
been signed to an amateur Tri out contract
because it was after the 5:00 deadline so he
is going to back up Dan badar there he is
in the warm-up can you imagine this story
developing in your own mind as he takes to
the ice and warm up and there it is a great
shot Logan Thompson the Calgary buffalo nickel
the Calgary Canuck no doubt ties there to one
another everybody kind of smiling taking this
all in obviously everybody hoping for the best
for Jacob markstrom but what a story right
now for nickel who's going to back up ldar
as we mentioned he's been in this close to this
situation in the past but nothing quite like this
battling into these loose pucks jari he's going
for the empty net bouncing towards the goal he
scores you have witnessed history
Tristan jari becomes the first
goenda goal wow was that with some authority
too and I know I said it before there's not
many goals that can do that Tristan jari had
himself a whale of a game and oh yeah he just
scored a goal brother simpling rivalry on display
here tonight with William nander up against Alex
nander both by the way drafted number eight in
their respective drafts watch the left foot here
the heel snags onto the post and the steal
comes right out of Jordan Bennington skate
and after that it's a little bit of free willing
in the crease there Fish Out of Water trying to
figure out how to keep his floting trying to use
some Edge work sliding around I can't imagine how
difficult that was for Jordan Bennington based
on the fact John that goalies use those edges so
effectively you come into another team's building
and you're beating them and then you're poking at
their goalie like you got to think there's going
to be a response of some sort he's talking to the
bench he's talking to his brother now stenin takes
a poke at him and this thing is going to heat up
again Grandma kachuck reaction after this but
a wave of emotions for both their grandsons in
this game tonight every player on the ice has
a 10-minute misconduct among other penalties
I have never Garrett rank you might be my hero I
have never heard that from an official everybody
on the ice and I don't remember the last time
I saw 10-minute miscon handed out to everybody
I thought he gave me one there he 219 to go and
even the spare goalie gets a chance to jump on the
bench lots of space that kind of is indicative
if you haven't tuned in and you're just tuning
in what's been going on here Hughes accelerates
he has Luke to his right he slides it across and
Luke Hugh scores Hugh squared and the devil's
win it he comes back take about Luke he scores
the game winner just held in at the line for
lin looks for wman again with Slap Shot Jake
wman the gritty the S Red Wings win it 5 to four
how cool is it feel to gritty your way off the
ice here tonight new uh new fortnite Season's out
so uh add me up I'm always on Pittsburgh P number
28 has a two-minute minor for holding you want
to join him you want to join him do you want to
join him Predator fans would be okay with that
t wanted to join him there's a lot of room over
on those respective team benches but not so much
in the penalty boxes starting to feel like Kings
Ducks isn't it Peter McDougall stopping team
are making changes and yeah he's from nearby
kishis college and wouldn't you know jod almost
400 penalty minutes kenish is alltime leader
in penalty minutes so he had a lot of experience
with officiating before he became a referee yeah
he had a lot of time to think about it sitting in
the Penalty Box I guess with all those penalties
that he racked up that's impressive that college
to get that many penalty minutes on him two at a
time right yeah now he's on the other side of it
and Rodriguez with a chance to win it in comes
Rodriguez scores and the Florida Panthers win
it 2-1 in the shootout and they're just calling
the players back on the Ed for a second to see he
wait a minute make sure that that was not double
touched in it was oh hang on hang on a second here
it was into the pad that back in of the stick it's
determined that the Florida player double tap
the puck this is wild and now fans are trying
to scream back into the building we had half the
bench for Florida's in the room Joseph wall was
long on he probably had a gear off here we go
again I don't remember that on a game winner
before it's the right call good recognition
get back in here hustle back everyone Noah
Gregor Works in fire my goodness did ever Here
Comes cousins hit the go post and no leaves with
it what a game what a crazy game what a difference
a couple of minutes makes have not seen that
especially that fast though I you know what I do
think it's important that they have rules oh it's
important we have them D with it for Minnesota
couldn't get it by Hall duim lost his stick on
the play knocks Hall to the ice and duim with a
strong play kicks it back to dur speaking of wind
Batts du loses his stick here but doesn't give up
on the play Paul just a little shov but how about
the skate pass from D to keep that Play Alive
rumbling through Center Malin lost his stick look
at the soccer move steps on it get Mal there's no
bad ideas I was wondering what he's going to do he
turned into Messi just looks for an exit wow we
just spoke about that whoa wow what a great fake
that was by orof oh it's Demitri orof oh he's
talking with mer leens right now long distance
he faked the dump in and merin's recovered and
made a great save oh see the smile there sneaky
sneaky Mr orloff and an Elvis is creeping to his
right but look at this oh he gets it deflects
it and then he's like no no no you almost got
me me that was great must be a buddy of Elvis
gamesmanship up on through Ain great look down
low at the goal line somehow that stays out that
is unbelievable it look like we stopped on
the goal line and there was a wide open net
Wilson's rebound is going to catch the back leg
of Blackwood and just spiral away from the goal
line shoots wide rebound out in front beater out
of the net go poovi they score beer out waited him
and shovel it home look at this the way that
it dribbled in there beer does a good job of
waiting but right about now he fans on it it was
going not in the net it was going along the goal
line and wide but it gets knocked in the Power
Play Goals against or the two short-handed goals
against from Dallas oh Matt so says I see your
glove save Mark Andre flurry wow but that got one
of my own wa where are those blockers and catchers
on the bench that would usually bang off the glass
and into the corner but M Soul guard backing
up tonight makes a save half away and a big
hit there as John ludig introduces himself to the
Battle of PA delore he'll change now but he tried
to earlier as he launched off of lmig right into
his own bench that was massive zacklin fumbled it
away but right to a teammate and then loose and
scored Coleman that shot coming through appeared
to clip Jamie Ben favorable bounce this one goes
off at Jamie Ben's hand he tries to glove it it
caught him right in the palm and then plopped down
perfectly for Coleman verser for Holtz and the one
timer by nemish and they score off the rebound as
it came hot off that glass behind coo kakan well
merer in the right place at the right time perfect
little bounce off the glass in behind and nemit is
the guy that fires that one there goes off of the
end wall coo and then off the top of the net the
cord will contain it good Hustle by tereno look
at out they score Drake Bon right here he just
lost it he's going to leave it for his defenseman
who is not there in the play and it just goes out
and then cousins will play it behind his own net
and this one fann on here's a chance Neo score he
set up L Zeller another turnover that winds up in
the back of the Sabers net all looks pretty simple
here and that puck just gets fanned on by doing
he's trying to go hard around and as he does NE
knows what to do right away it's quick strike
noris Trophy winner Drew dowy best sign I've
ever seen here at crypto in warmup my nana thinks
you're hot that brings Drew back he's no longer a
kid there he goes he's laughing about it oh you
got it season number 16 for Drew dowy here's a
three onone the other way for New Jersey and it's
off the crossbar the horn sounds to indicate a
goal but it never went in some premature hornage
here in New Jersey got to give a little love to
your goalie 40 saves for gorg up tonight I think
it started with his haircut he was looking sharp
from from this morning and KBS brings it up ice
digs to the net but chov comes way out to poke it
off his stick he's still out of the net and Joe
scores Joe stayed with the play in front of the
net and the Sabers get their second of the night
with 1036 to go in the third it's 6-2 Carolina
yeah joose just going to redirect this one into
the net second of the Year here looks it back
across the top he's got room he shoots he fired
that just wide the top of the C with a chance
they score piny on the rebound and Chicago comes
back to Win It 43 and Le still trying to figure
out how that win in shot went wide came back over
the top of the net off the glass and here's a shot
that catches the top of Samson on Stick oh it's
a one-handed effort by Kinski who stays with it
nobody knew where it was set for Pinsky you
hope he comes right back and looks as good as
he did when he left he certainly has thus far well
Little Miss Q here and it's in the back of the net
Sam Reinhardt second of the night as this one just
gets kind of easily dumped in and when he stops it
it gets away from him and Bennett beats everybody
down low first career penalty shot for spraw and
it's a goal Daniel sprong Henrik Zetterberg Nick
bronwell like that two to go one to go F down deep
buuk stand shoots save by gor of score oh man as
I look at that again kale may have tried to put
this underneath gorv and may have stuck it under
his own net minder Mo you seen what I'm seing I
did kale tried to get in and put on the pad and a
might have gone through the five hole off K fetch
nikov gets to it behind the net he thinks about
the lacrosse move huge save picker on Camy and
then he anticipated you see how he stood up he's
not a bigger guy he knew that was coming right
now he's trying to get a handle on his mouth guard
these are the issues that you have when you have a
full bubble on I did it myself I broke a cheekbone
I had to play with the cage for a few weeks coming
well and that was the case here in this one
Flyers thir it all the way down he rolling
toward the interet and from long range the Flyers
make it five to2 and that is playing the bank the
roll and everything else perfectly maybe we pick
the player of the game a little too soon huh and
he'll say he playing that all the way he roll
on its Edge right to the center of the net uh
not easy to do stop that turnover and cder scores
right off the draw the Flyers turned it over and
prder beats hard from in close two nothing Rangers
less than two minutes in the B off Wi exactly what
you want and Travis sanine put it right on the
tape there of Chris krider standing by with actor
Seth Rogan right now and Seth you dropped the
puck how was that being out there between two
captains out in Center Ice they're very large men
they that was my first impression and prevailing
thought was these dudes are humongous absolutely
they they're big and one of them was missing some
tee that makes sense as you would hope yes it
felt very real as a Canadian it was nostalgic for
me Flames have it sharp angle and they score and
put this one away a couple of stars break their
sticks as frustration shows there goes about
$600 worth of sticks the hand off for tanet
centering feed and it banked in never got to its
intended receiver and kumed in behind Wedgewood
Brian sud's had a couple of these caram in off
him like this he's trying to defend goes off
the skate I think Capp in two onone and a pass to
Ley in the cair CH he scores a short-handed goal
by Ley and the bles have tied the game now
D jenko he comes in shoots he scars another
short-handed Bal and the blows are feasting on
the short-handed situation on this Thanksgiving
Eve and they lead again what an incredible
turn of events here and William neander to
extend his point streak and win the game for
Toronto that's off the pipe and I thought it
went in it goes post crossbar and out I thought
at first it was in the net I got no reaction from
neander mon knocked it away benw with a Chance
oh neander hit the goal post rebound loing but
st's got it back neander had the open cage and
hit the PIP dander back with it oh and shoot
hit the go you'd like to have a word with that
goal post first could have been worse it could
have been worse early as he stops his Puck and
he's like where is everybody and is someone not
coming back to get it a little frustration
that just communication and just not on the
same page yeah I me there's always some chirping
back and forth he likes telling me he he makes
a lot more than I do uh doesn't really bother
me so a lot of lot of players make a lot more
than I do so uh it's not really a good one but
yeah it just happens in the Heat of the Moment
usually yeah I think I said that once long time
ago sounds like he's holding on to it make that
five wins in a row for the Arizona Coyotes all
against the most recent Stanley Cup champions
slay Goliath I absolutely love it I think one of
the fans had a pretty cool sheet that they were
holding in their hands with all of the the first
four of those off tonight and right as this game
was winding down they scratched off that last one
for the capitals but what a fun run Florida with
another big Atlantic division game tomorrow look
out right in front scores lenan gets the puck and
it's a gift to tap it in and make it 5 nothing
for the Panthers terce enko bounces it back to
Zub and as he gets it off the Dasher board he
starts to stumble it goes off his left skate
and goes right back into the front of the net
and when it rains it pours and that look says it
all